[Music]
however in the form in which the notion
of pure insight first makes its
appearance it is not yet realized
accordingly its consciousness still
appears as contingent as single and
separate and its essence appears for it
in the form of an end which it has to
realize it has to begin with the
intention of making pure insight
Universal that is of making everything
that is actual into a notion and into
one and the same notion in every
self-consciousness the intention is pure
for it has pure insight for its content
and this insight is likewise pure for
its content is solely the absolute
notion which meets with no opposition at
an object nor is it restricted in its
own self in the unrestricted notion they
are directly found the two aspects that
everything objective has only the
significance of being for self of self
consciousness and that this has the
significance of a universal that pure
insight is to become the property of
every self consciousness this second
aspect of the intention as a result of
culture in so far as in this culture the
difference of objective spirit the parts
and the determinations which its
judgments imposed on the world as well
as the differences which appear as
natural predispositions have all been
upset genius talent special capacities
generally belong to the world of
actuality insofar as this world still
contains the aspect of being a spiritual
Animal Kingdom in which individuals
admits confusion and mutual violence
cheat and struggle over the essence of
the actual world these differences it is
true have no place in this world as
honest especi neither is contented with
the unreal matter in hand itself nor he
has at a particular content and ends of
its own on the contrary it counts merely
as something universally acknowledged
that is as an educated individuality and
the the difference is reduced to one of
less or more energy a quantitative
difference that is a nonessential
difference this last difference
however it has been effaced by the fact
that in the completely disrupted state
of consciousness difference changed
round into an absolutely qualitative
difference there what is for the eye and
other is only the eye itself in this
infinite judgment all one-sidedness and
peculiarity of the original being for
self has been eradicated the self knows
itself quoi pure self to be its own
object and this absolute identity of the
two sides is the element of pure insight
pure insight is therefore the simple
eminently differentiated essence and
equally the universal work or
achievement and a universal possession
in this simple spiritual substance self
consciousness gives itself and preserves
for itself in every object the
consciousness of this its own particular
being or of its own action just as
conversely the individuality of self
consciousness is there in self identical
and universal this pure insight is thus
the spirit that calls to every
consciousness be for yourselves what you
all are in yourselves reasonable
paragraph 537 is one of the longest in
this this short section faith and
insight and it brings it to a close in a
very important way that has us thinking
both of the world of culture that we've
come from and then you know moved out
into with faith and pure insight and the
dialectic between those two and where
we're going which is the concept or the
the notion that pequeña of pure insight
which is what Hegel is calling the
Enlightenment the ALF Clara right and
he's going to devote a lot of discussion
to the ins and outs of that in in the
section to come as a matter of fact
Hegel takes that at least in really the
rationality of the world but but in
particular Western rationality as being
one of the defining moments part of a
movement that is still going on within
Europe at the time that he himself is is
writing and it's playing itself out so
how do we get there this this notion of
of pure insight that you know Hegel is
is spelling out he says it's not yet
realized so what is it going to take for
it to actually be realized what does it
mean to be realized to begin with it
means for it to be made via click actual
to be made part of the world and one of
the hallmarks of hegelian philosophy in
fact the slogan that a lot of people
will associate it with is the real is
rational and the rational is real that
really fits in here with what is is
happening in this paragraph the dynamic
that Hegel is talking about but it
should be amended to say the real should
be rational the rational should be real
because until we get to the final state
of the Hegelian dialectic which is
debatable about you know whether we
actually really did reach it the way
Hegel thinks we can't say that
that this has been fully worked out so
what we have here is a moment where
Hegel is describing precisely what it
would mean for the rational to be real
but for the rational to become real
which means that it has to rationalize
everything else and just to bring
everything else within the scope of
reason and not just reason but spirit so
Hegel says in the form which the notion
of pure insight first makes its
appearance we're gonna see this pure
insight being played out in it
throughout the entire next section
insight is going to come up over and
over again so we've only introduced pure
insight we haven't fully worked out what
pure insight is he says in the the form
in which the notion makes its appearance
it is not yet realized so what does this
mean
he says accordingly its consciousness
still appears as contingent as single
and separate and its essence appears to
it as an end and the end is all this
over here the end is a universal
something outside something beyond
something transcending the mere
individual but actually reincorporating
the contingent individual and all the
other individuals at least in principle
as well now we should dwell for a moment
on what exactly we have in mind in
talking about the contingent individual
how does this fit in with the historical
process as Hegel sees it playing itself
out leading up to an actual historical
movement of the Enlightenment I've
mentioned in the past that we can look
at this entire discussion of faith and
pure insight as applying to you know
certain parts of the Middle Ages but
primarily applying to the early modern
period particularly you know from from
we could think about what happens in the
Reformation and all the difference you
know
dialectical advances
there which what angle doesn't talk much
about and then think about what happens
in the criticisms of religion the
reinterpretations of religion so who
would this contingent individual be well
it might be Thomas Hobbes
it might be Bishop Berkeley it might be
Benedict Spinoza it might be Rene
Descartes who is telling us that
theology can have its domain because
that is so far above us and we're going
to stick with metaphysics and you know
the things that come from it turning
back to the world with mechanics
medicine and morals right it could be
all sorts of individuals who are
contingent individuals they are part of
what we nowadays call a culture war and
quite often they are the lone century
stationed up on the hill who can surveil
the
enemy forces far below realize that
they're surrounded and yet try to make a
stand as best as they possibly can so
the contingent individual has a goal a
goal of realizing something that they
themselves experienced something that
they themselves have as part of who they
are an integral part this pure insight
but now for others so he says its
essence appears for it in the form of an
end its essence is outside of itself its
essence is over here in the form of an
end which it has to realize it has to
produce it has to bring about so he says
it has to begin with the intention of
making pure insight Universal now what
does this mean
Hegel is going to tell us that this has
to do with making everything actual into
a notion let's make it a little bit more
concrete what was Rene Descartes in
effect doing with his meditations
is discourse which was an introduction
to three parts of his unpublished the
world he suppressed the publication of
it after the Galileo incident what was
he doing with his principles of
philosophy what was he doing with all
the correspondence that he carried on he
was attempting to lead people to use
their unaided reason a well regulated
reason to understand the world
themselves society God the universe in a
different way in a way that would be
certain that would have to do with clear
and distinct ideas putting them together
in a systematic way which is what you
see for example if you ever do read his
principles of philosophy most people
only read the discourse and the
meditations but the principles are
really where the core stuff is and
Descartes is really a great
representative of this because he writes
in the vernacular for some of his works
let you know for example the discourse
on method is written in French why
because as opposed to the meditations
written in Latin which were only
accessible to men and scholars he says
well the discourse can be read by women
who probably don't read Latin although
he actually did have some Latin
correspondence right princess Latin
writings and and reading correspondence
like Princess Elizabeth and common
people Descartes has the ambition that
we see in the early modern period
leading into the Enlightenment of taking
that that pure insight and making it
something accessible something available
to everybody and thereby changing the
world in the process now Hegel frames
this in terms of making everything that
is actual into a notion that means that
everything has to be brought within the
scope of philosophy or it is cast
outside of it as something irrational
absurd
uh none essential right so the essential
whatever is essential
can be turned into notions can be turned
into BKA and this could be notions in
the sense of you know just ideas or it
could be notions in the sense of a
systematic philosophical approach to
things which is what we see so many
projects carrying out at this time you
know it's very important when we think
about the history of philosophy to
actually read not just the the you know
one or two works that we get assigned in
an in a modern philosophy class but to
read across a person's corpus you don't
really know what Thomas Hobbes is up to
if you only read portions of the
Leviathan you need to also read some of
his correspondence you need to
understand that he was engaged with Rene
Descartes in a rather unproductive
exchange you need to read the other
treatises you need to also read the
behemoth similarly if you're going to
you know study Spinoza don't just read
the ethics also read the you know
attract hottest theological Politico
because there's so much involved there
likewise with dick Hart you should you
should read more and not to mention
David Hume or John Locke you know
portions of the essay concerning human
understanding and the Second Treatise of
government they're great but he wrote a
lot more the letter on toleration for an
example very short work but very
important for Locke's for understanding
what Locke's project was or his you know
works on education so we can say making
everything that is actually into a
notion and now notice what he says into
one in the same notion in every
self-consciousness this also is is
rather key what we see in modern
philosophy and what we see really in in
the entire scope of letters that are
affected by the the turn to modern
philosophy so I would say literature I
would say even the theater also history
is this emphasis on things must be made
intelligible
you all that is a hallmark this is what
we see take heart for example using as
almost like a weapon or a battering ram
to to knock down previous ways of
looking at things Thomas Hobbes uses the
same same approach so does Locke and he
says one of the same notion and every
self-consciousness we're gonna be
looking at the field of everybody
everybody is is at least theoretically
able to partake in this that's the goal
that's the end
definitely not realized not even realize
that our own time but that is what pure
insight at this point in time is
dreaming about that is the great project
you might say of the Enlightenment that
we're soon going to be looking at so now
he says this intention is pure because
it has pure insight for its content why
does that make it pure couldn't pure
insight have an ulterior Genda well pure
insight is operating very much as you
know this is a typical Hegelian
dialectic as has all these other shapes
of consciousness before it it is firmly
committed to its point of view and it's
going to work it out
if pure insight really was just kind of
a partisan project deployed selectively
to attack opponents it really wouldn't
be pure insight it would be motivated
insight it would be interested in sight
pure insight is able to have the
dialectical weight and make the advances
that it does precisely because it is
pure insight and it's going to end up
turning on itself as we're going to see
so he says the intention is pure for it
has pure insight as its content right
the optics has Isaac for its content and
this insight is likewise pure for its
content he says is solely the absolute
notion the absolute notion the
unrestricted nothing else standing in
its way as Hegel describes it here it
meets no opposition
in an object it can cover everything
philosophy and this is something I think
that a lot of people have lost sight of
in the contemporary philosophy of our
own time philosophy at one time had the
ambition of reaching out and
understanding and integrating everything
we see this still as a a conception of
philosophy in the 19th century and even
in parts of the 20th century and various
traditions of philosophy philosophy is
the field that should in fact try to
extend itself to everything all of its
others everything that is opposed to it
if it doesn't do so if like you know
what happened in analytic philosophy
it's sort of you know shrinks itself in
and says oh that's that's for the
sciences and that stuff over there is
you know I'm thinking about you know
logical positive that's nonsense because
that's ethics and and religion we're
just going to do this little logical
analysis here that sees this to be
philosophy from Hegel's perspective and
from the perspective of so many other
philosophers including those of the
moderns even the ones who appear to be
skeptical even the ones who appear to be
careful and say oh I'm just you know a
laborer like Locke you know clearing
away some of the rubble read Locke's
works and you see that is definitely not
the case
he has ambition for philosophy to try to
cover as much as possible even a manual
Conte who in a certain way might be
viewed as one of the most skeptical of
philosophers because he takes the the
noumenon you know and casts it way
behind the veil of phenomena that will
never actually get to it he himself has
the ambition of applying philosophy to
everything you know great example is
religion read you know religion within
the limits of reason alone it's an
ethics treatise it's not a treatise
about religion at all
so Hegel goes on we go on with Hegel
rather and he says the absolute notion
is it meets with no opposition at an
object nor is it restricted in its own
self this is really integral to
philosophy as well philosophy is
supposed to be reflexive it is supposed
to ask questions not only about
everything else
but also of itself it's supposed to try
to encompass everything and if it
doesn't encompass everything it can ask
at least the question why can't I
understand this so he goes on and he
says in the unrestricted notion there
are two aspects that are found
everything objective has only the
significance of being for self of self
consciousness and this has the
significance of a universal that pure
insight is to become the property of
every self consciousness the world is
now understood as a world for subjects
for self conscious subjects and every
single one of them is to become aware of
this again a dream that has not been
realized fully and and probably we can
never point at a time where even say
half the people were living in the way
that the the person of pure insight the
person who is at that gestalt you know
that that shape of consciousness is
envisioning but this drives historical
development and here we're starting to
move to look at the realm of culture and
what is occurring there so he says the
second aspect of the intention is a
result of culture insofar as in this
culture the difference of objective
spirit the parts and the determinations
which judgments opposed on the world as
well as the differences which appear as
natural predispositions have all been
upset so the the sort of self
contradiction of culture and the
sophisticated individual caught within
it who engaged in the witty repartee now
finds something else now has opened the
door to the person of insight who looks
at that culture and says we want
something better for people than this
morass this this mess we don't want to
just be like the naive individual who
thinks that we can go back
to an earlier stage of culture no we
have to move forward so he says all of
these differences genius talents special
capacities these belong to he says the
world of actuality insofar as this world
contains the aspect of being a spiritual
Animal Kingdom now this is an this is a
a frame of reference that we have used
before and we're coming back to again
what is a spiritual animal kingdom let's
remind ourselves of that the animal
kingdom is you know this this sort of
highest organization of life and you got
all these different species and they're
all related in in different ways and at
the same time there's really no meaning
to it it's just a a mishmash of all
sorts of things that have happened to
have evolved or developed or have been
created whatever metaphysics you like
there's no intrinsic rationality to it
we can look at things that say okay it's
rational the way that this this set of
bones articulated but that's us the
rational subjects looking at we've
already talked about this with the
reason section the spiritual animal
kingdom has to do with human beings why
is that guy a butcher that guy an iron
worker that guy a ruler that guy a
scholar you know where is everybody else
how do they end up in these roles seems
to be rather contingent everyone does
their thing and we have this giant sort
of organism or cosmos of whatever you
want to call it the political community
the city the society everybody doing
their thing within it but it doesn't
have any movement towards something more
something of value something of
universal value so he says these
differences
well the spiritual animal kingdom is one
in which individuals admits confusion
and mutual violence cheat and struggle
over the essence of the actual world
they do all try to strive for what they
view as important well
our you know social prestige getting to
have sex you know other pleasures
avoiding pains living in a you know
house on a hill whatever whatever floats
your boat you might say right all these
people imagine sort of a whole bunch of
people swarming all over each other like
an anthill but at least an anthill has
organization this is just ants gone
crazy Hagel says well that is what you
know culture is like at least from the
perspective of pure insight because
these differences he says have no place
in this world as honest species
individuality
neither is contented with the unreal
matter and hand itself the the sokka's
Alps that we talked about nor has it a
particular content and ends of its own
now this is really interesting on the
contrary it counts merely as something
universally acknowledged individuality
in order to be valued as individuality
requires some recognition in a universal
way now notice that at this point Hegel
is no longer talking about just
recognition I need recognition from the
other and this one single other will
suffice now he's saying it needs
recognition from the society from the
universal this doesn't necessarily mean
from every single person but from what
is really essential in it so he says
these differences are reduced to one of
less or more energy a quantitative
difference a non-essential difference
what are these differences well let's
think again genius talent special
capacities if you happen to have you
know more capacity for one thing and I
have more capacity for another those are
merely quantitative differences they
don't affect the fact that we're all
capable of this pure insight which
should be universalized
throughout the society all those other
things that fit in here with the
spiritual annika animal kingdom those
don't really matter that much they're
their differences
is that don't really make a difference
it's sort of like you know asking I
listen I need to take an uber to get
myself to the to the train station and
you know the car pulls up and you're
like oh that's a red car who cares it
doesn't matter what matters is is that
car going to get you to the station
it's a to theater it's a four-seater
it's a convertible well okay that would
matter a bit you know for winter here in
Wisconsin but most of these differences
do not make a difference they have an
air freshener the car smells bad
who cares you're getting out of the car
and getting on that train similarly we
can say you know that about all these
other traits that that we think make a
person who they are or these things that
they happen to have at a certain time
within the spiritual animal kingdom this
guy's in charge well you know wait a
couple weeks somebody else will be in
charge or go over there and and talk to
that person because they're in charge
these things are non-essential
differences from Hegel's perspective he
says this last difference has been
effaced by the fact that in the
completely disrupted state of
consciousness difference changed around
into an absolutely qualitative
difference what is the qualitative
difference that of faith and insight an
insight is where we're looking at this
point he says there what is for the eye
and other is only the eye itself should
we see here what we call an effacement
of Altera T in Hegel something he's been
accused of so many times you know not
treating the other as the other this is
only a transitory stage each of us gets
to realize that the other is an other
eye this is something that was there in
the self consciousness section right and
back then it led to conflict now it
doesn't actually have to lead to
conflict now it can start to lead to
reconciliation or to integration if I
awaken in another person
the pure insight that is available to
them and in in doing so you know realize
that they are another eye who is not
truly other to me but is actually like
myself I'm not hurting them in the
process I'm not making them less what
they are I'm actually allowing them to
be what they are and it's reversible I
could be the one over here that Spinoza
or Descartes or whoever enlightens about
this this sort of stuff and then pass it
on to another person so he says the self
knows itself QWOP yourself to be its own
object and this absolute identity of the
two sides is the element of pure insight
this is what allows us to have this
communicative relationship I can make an
argument to you I can provide you with
evidence and you can say ah yes I do
grasp that or wait a second what about
this and in in that wait a second what
about this I am myself being treated as
another eye to your eye who is engaging
in pure insight and this is how pure
insight actually functions it's not the
property of just an individual it's
something that is supposed to be made
social so he says pure insight is
therefore the simple eminently
differentiated essence and equally now
notice what he says here this is really
interesting the universal work or
achievement and a universal possession
that's worth dwelling on the universal
worker achievement and a universal
possession in laboring for oneself
within the field of pure insight the way
that modern philosophers did they
created something some things that
lasted beyond themselves that were
intended already for publication for
dissemination for allowing other people
to do something with their minds do
something with their lives do something
with their societies in relation to
others they may not have had the perfect
recipe in every case maybe we reject
Cartesian dualism or we say well Leibniz
was wrong about this or Locke was wrong
about
but the guiding impulse the spirit
behind it the absolute notion that's
driving it is one that Hegel thinks can
be shared and passed on can become a
universal work or achievement Universal
possession so he says in this simple
spiritual substance self-consciousness
gives itself and preserves for itself in
every object the consciousness of this
its own particular being or its own
action and then he says conversely the
individuality or self-consciousness is
there in self identical and universal
this is a way of making oneself
universal now notice how he ends this
and this is leading us right into this
section of enlightenment this pure
insight is thus the spirit that calls to
every consciousness be for yourselves
what you all are in yourselves
reasonable we're all reasonable in
ourselves but we have to realize that
for ourselves which means realizing it
not only in a reflexive relation to our
own selves but in relation to others as
well and understanding ourselves as not
mere particular individuals so we don't
want to lose sight of that but as part
of something larger something universal
you